Throughout this course we'll be using
an example application called app.
In our app we have three applications.
Monolith, Hello and Off Service.
The Monolith service combines
authentication and Hello micro services.
Let's run the monolithic application
now to see how it works.
Our application is built and we can
test this functionality using curl and
we can see we got a response back.
It's working.
Now let's try the secure end point.
The request fails because
we need to get a JWT token.
>From the log in end point.
So let's do that now.
I'm going to tie password at the prompt.
Now that I have a JWT token, can I can
hit the secure end point using curl and
it should work.
As expected everything is working now.
A couple of things about the example
service I should point out.
While it's a monolithic application.
It does leverage many principles
found in 12 factor applications.
For example,
we are logging to standard output so
logging tools can pick up our logs
without touching any log files.
You'll also notice the model of
application is self-contained.
We are but only all of our
dependencies in the vendor directory.
Following these practices make our
application easier to maintain and
deploy to the cloud, something
we're striving for in this course.
I'll kick it over to Carter to
explain more about 12 factor and
micro services in depth.